all right should we talk about
astroworld yeah yeah
tragic man eight people dead yeah
uh a bunch more in the hospital even
more in the bunch more in the hospital
have you guys heard this thing about the
needle yes yeah this is what's really
interesting to me i'm curious the if the
people died from the trampling from uh
some sort of asphyxiation or from
fentanyl or whatever the [ __ ] was in
that needle apparently there was a guy
walking around just jabbing people with
the knee i don't know if that's
confirmed yet is it the police say
they're still investigating it but i've
read the the stories like the really
detailed ones of how people were getting
crushed in the stampede and you just
know if there were some people that were
injured from that needle
definitely a lot of people were killed
within that stampede they were crushed i
read some accounts that basically once
travis scott got on stage everybody
tried to rush to the front and some girl
was saying like she lined up dumb early
like an hour and a half before the
concert even started to be close and
then when travis came on stage it was
like crazy pain like it was so tight
literally i think she said if you jumped
you just stayed in the air it was that
tight you felt it on your ribs people
are shoving in she passed out and then
luckily they were like finding people
who were passed out and then crowd
surfing them out of the way she helped
one person then she passed out and then
somebody helped her and then the eight
who died it seemed like they just got
trampled yeah like the the needle thing
it would be [ __ ] crazy if it's true
right now it's not confirmed
did confirm that one security guard
allegedly
he said that the security guard claims
that he got a needle in the neck and
then had to be resuscitated with narcan
yeah
now some people are suggesting that the
nypd is putting the needle story out and
like trying to push the needle store
because it absolves them hpd or the
is putting out the story and like
pushing the needle story
because they're like dude there's a
crazy guy with a needle it's not because
there was poor crowd controls not
because of anything else
it was a wild attacker
and also multiple things can be true
yikes yeah it is kind of crazy but there
is an interesting conversation
which is like responsibility
for
mob
tactics
here yeah okay go ahead because i have a
so
and again i don't hold i don't hold uh
travis responsible in the same way that
i don't hold like trump responsible for
like inciting violence or inciting these
things right like you can say something
but if somebody actually does it they
should be personally accountable for
that especially if they're an adult
right
uh that being said
people are gonna look into travis's
marketing and they're gonna show that he
makes sure you know every single time
that a mob chases him and he is the type
of person that uh mobs create around him
and he's the type of person that people
will charge the gate and he's the type
he is that famous he's that excited 2015
he played
guilty to i think reckless endangerment
endangerment because he told the crowd
to hop over the barricades uh i think
2017 in manhattan a guy sued him because
he said he got shoved off a third floor
balcony and then dragged on stage so
this is a thing that he's already had
part of the issues with yeah so
when that happens and you don't do super
lit dawg it looks in the astro world
promo for this year they used footage
from previous concerts that show people
breaking down gates and jumping over
fences and they're like yo this is the
craziest thing ever hundreds of kids
just running he says that he wants his
shows to be like a wwe show and yeah
he's promoting that moshiach and he's
saying that's the release but apparently
he tweeted earlier that day encouraging
gay crashing
when he said we want the wild ones in or
sometimes yeah we're sneaking the wild
ones in we're still sneaking people in
blah blah and apparently the event was
oversold
yeah
so it's like there's a bunch of people
probably on the hook yeah we got to
figure out what the issue was if the
issue is just simply overcrowding then
maybe it could be those people that came
in through the crash gate and if they
came into the crash gate because they
felt like travis was telling them to do
that is he partially responsible a bunch
of issues right yeah that's at least
what they're gonna say when this goes to
a lawsuit right yeah the lawsuits are
gonna say listen he told [ __ ]
to crash this [ __ ] and the people that
crashed it caused the overcrowding which
caused the people to be squeezed and
trampled and [ __ ] up and if it was
only the amount of people that were
there right if they didn't oversell it
if they oversold it then they also
whoever oversold it is on the hook as
well it's just a really interesting
situation it's like how much can you
hype the crowd how much can you reward
it like every time travis is being
chased i don't even think he walks
the only time i see him is he's being
chased he's at mcdonald's people going
crazy and they're they're mobbing it
right he's in fashion week people going
crazy they're mobbing it like almost to
the point where i'm like
is he paying
to like start this kind of thing is he
paying a few select people to like chase
him when he goes somewhere because it
makes it look super hypey yeah right it
does look hypey you look like you're the
man people are chasing you through the
streets yeah that's a superhero you can
also just put yourself in a position
that that happens like if you're not
paying everyone to chase you like you
can go through the front entrance of the
concert where everyone that's there to
see you sees you and they can walk up to
you and all of a sudden that's going to
create panic like he could go through
the back door yeah there's other
entrances there's better security
details there's disguises like but he's
intentionally drawing attention to get
people to it is also i've been to a
travis scott
small live performance he did while it
out one year and i went to go hang out
like 2016. i wasn't on it but i was just
saying hi to everybody and that
[ __ ] had the whole place shaking
like i've never seen any live
performance ever like he's actually
incredible live and he creates his
energy i can't even explain it i walked
out toward the end of the performance
but you could literally feel the whole
venue shaking it was crazy it was the
[ __ ]
story i ever heard but yeah yeah fire
events so live going crazy i got to bed
early but it was crazy
shelton's bachelor party lit is [ __ ]
about 2 a.m you guys you guys good
i'm gonna go to sleep try to get eight
hours
that is true our guys will go to sleep
every night early makes me feel better
you did that for travis scott too not be
doing that no that's me
said that like this event had it's a
festival right it was 50 000 people but
normally when you're at a festival
you're at coachella there's a main stage
and then all the people that want house
music are in like far off in the sahara
tent so that whole crowd is distributed
across the field anyone going to
astroworld festival the entire show will
be
there for travis yeah so that's what
doug is saying is there's multiple bands
playing at the same time yeah and
usually they're bands that don't have
any kind of crossover right with the
listenership right but at astroworld
there's one person you want to see but
at the same time like they should be
ready for that like yeah when jay-z
comes on it i don't know if he's ever
played coachella like everybody's going
to see jay-z rock the bells you want to
chill i mean this is going to have an
effect on all of it because coachella
has been the same exact
fields in in palm springs or in
coachella area and the audience uh
capacity just keeps on growing they've
expanded a little bit but like
triple what it was when we were going
like 15 years ago and you feel it like
people are lined up two hours before
there's still room but you're like you
know you're that's going to change big
time what do you think you're just not
going to have these big concerts or the
capacities capacity has to has to be
reduced
yeah yeah
are you what do you think do you think
travis is the greatest artist of all
time yes i'll say i think there's like
i've seen examples so i've been like
reading up on like reddit stuff and
they're like yo i was at a concert that
was in uh glass in the uk let's say and
it was a hundred barriers yeah yeah it's
a hundred thousand people but they had
rows that were forcefully like layered
in and security would kick people out
that would step the right side you're
supposed to do it yeah there was like
there are people that apparently do this
correctly with larger crowds i'm not
like i just imagine
people are wild yeah i just imagine that
those people maybe are going to elevate
like to a bigger career you know i mean
like those people that handle this well
i also think yeah travis doesn't seem
like he wants it he wants to [ __ ] i
want you guys to swarm yeah yeah and you
could tell like make for a crazy energy
the fervor in the audience when like
they're bringing the ambulance through
and kids are jumping on the ambulance
like twerking and like stomping on it
and like trying to break [ __ ] and
apparently he saw the ambulance stop the
music for like uh several seconds is
what i heard
and then he was like what's going on
there's an ambulance his music stops and
then he goes if you're doing all right
put your middle finger up and then he
went back into 30 more minutes
yeah so
i i don't necessarily blame him but it
ain't a good look yeah apparently the
event went on 30 minutes after it was
already declared like a mass casualty
so it continued for 30 minutes after
there was reports and apparently people
were telling him like yo there's people
we might need to stop and allegedly i
don't know if it's true he said no [ __ ]
all that let's keep going
oh that would be he's on a massive
platform and he sees like multiple
people getting resuscitated he keeps on
doing the robot
you see his statement yo here's i didn't
see these things doing the robot bro he
was he was hitting the robot he was also
killing it too i was like damn i get it
murder that [ __ ]
there's that you found a nice pocket you
can't we gotta let him finish yeah
that's that's tricky man that's tricky
because you are at
a concert
and people are taking drugs and they're
going to pass out yeah
so
i'm sure it's not the first time a
massive entertainer has seen someone
pass out that's true in the audience and
there's 50 000 people there normalized
yeah especially when you go to these big
[ __ ] concerts especially his concert
yeah people are smoking weed they're
dehydrated they're doing [ __ ] ecstasy
jumping like screaming for two hours
like seeing people pass out is nothing
death is crazy but how do you know the
difference that's what i'm saying he
probably doesn't know the difference
he's seen it a million times and that's
not really facing him that much maybe
the ambulance did a little bit but
bro like seeing somebody passed out like
i'm just thinking like at burning man or
even like at a comp at a at a festival
or something like that that wouldn't be
that shocking to me
yeah it just wouldn't i don't know i
wouldn't
yeah that's a good point i'd expect
that's a good point but that's going to
be tough to explain
if you get sued which is already
starting to get suitable oh in
retrospect you look awful yeah you look
so cold right yeah you knew these
[ __ ] you knew these
[ __ ] dead you kept on singing
you kept saying put your mother middle
finger up and he can't exactly say oh
yeah i'm used to people just passing out
yeah and they're looking like they're
dead in my car they do all kinds of
drugs in my concert yeah you can't say
that but how does he know that they're
dead he has no clue so
that also falls on his management that's
like yo are you getting feed and intel
from like the medical team oh fam once
they know that somebody's dead someone
got to go on that stage
hey it's a wrap yeah yeah like one
person should have flare guns honestly
they should be inside the crowd that's a
good no they really should if you see
the flare go up be like yo that's it
automatic 30 minutes but i'll tell you
what's probably going to happen is
[ __ ] going to bring flare guns
to just [ __ ] party and just be like
this [ __ ] is fire
yeah that's crazy about that needle
though
yeah i don't even like that that's a
story because it's gonna give
[ __ ] ideas
like
what if he's just injecting him with a
vaccine yeah it could be cool what are
we just a big scientist
i'm just saying like what if you're one
of these crazy serial killers you're one
of these crazy [ __ ] right like
do you want to give everybody aids you
want to give everybody you know some
sort of disease you got some ebola you
know you want to give somebody that like
you just go around jabbing [ __ ]
and you're so close they won't even feel
it like honestly in a concert that's
that tight
you can just walk by people poke and
they'll be like oh what was that they'll
think it's a bug
bro you're probably drunk you don't even
need to do that you can literally offer
people free [ __ ] ecstasy laced with
fentanyl like oh [ __ ] yeah true much
easier
because the poking people you gotta have
mad different needles throw one out
throw another one out like yeah you can
also be on the hook for that people
would be like oh yeah i saw the guy that
came out to my friend and gave him some
[ __ ] he looked like this yeah
you just focused in and out secret yeah
yo
you gotta return before i [ __ ] won't
see the person yeah but when you're this
shit-faced you know what i mean
you're crazy
to travis's defense i don't know if he's
drunk like a lot of times performers are
on stage like they're faded like they
might not be like fully able to make
coherent decisions especially on that
scale yeah but again i don't think any
of that flies in court that might maybe
the court of public opinion maybe but
other people are going to be like yeah
but it's still your responsibility
well no i think legally he might be off
the hook
i think public opinion is going to be
harder on him than the legal president
yeah
i think that they're going to treat him
like alec baldwin man like i think
they're going to be like oh man he's the
victim in this well i honestly think
that statement hurt him because that was
his statement
his apology was he just literally he's
just saying he's just rubbing his
forehead the entire time weirdly just
doing this and just looks weird visually
but also though the [ __ ] he's saying is
almost more like hey guys don't be mad
at me it doesn't really it's not super
awkward but it's like i just want you
guys to know my fans mean the world to
me and all this stuff and i'm gonna do
you know i'm gonna set up a fund and
yeah i think i didn't hear a set of
buffon i've already said like i'm gonna
give you all information as soon as i
get it and it's like bro we don't care
about the information i want take care
of the people well he said he was like
i'm going to set up a fun try we're
figuring out the families we're trying
to help the families in this tough time
blah blah but he also put a filter on it
yeah he'll put a filter on your apology
bro it was black and white
yeah don't make it black and white bro
come on yeah i don't know better super
emotional it just yeah he it almost
looked like he was trying to cry but he
couldn't
forehead scratch yeah it didn't feel
super genuine music a little sarah
mcgloth he should have been helped yeah
that's a dope name for a female rapper
yeah sarah
mcglock yeah yeah
damn okay so you think that he has to
pay any money at all or not
no because i think he's like
yeah i don't think it's gonna be him
personally it's gonna be like the
event like vendors like probably like
the medical team that was hired because
apparently a bunch of them were
incompetent right is gonna fall in like
the production and whoever produced the
event yeah probably his management i
can't imagine if like comes out of his
pocket
there's insurance but then if he was at
fault if they could say that he and
caused this then they'll turn on him the
insurance is going to do everything in
their power to convince
the courts or whoever it is
that travis scott made these people
right yeah and he encouraged it and he
said this and the fragrance this tweet
promoter
i think yeah so if they can prove that
he encouraged the violence then yeah
it'll be on him [ __ ]
yeah
and then how does that change concerts
i don't know i don't know if we stopped
the mosh pit
yeah kind of i don't know if it's going
to change it that much though people die
every year black friday it that's true
that's true but i'm just saying like
if you know that you're on the hook for
it yeah right yeah with black friday i
don't think that the company itself is
on the hook but if if what was it called
was it best buy if best buy was on the
hook every time someone died at black
five please believe that they would have
some different rules
and once these artists got to start
paying or these promoters have to start
paying like if the promoter of this
event has to pay please believe anybody
else this event that they're promoting
is gonna have very different rules so
they can avoid another payment i think
if you're that type of artist a fire pr
move is to say yo you gotta sign a
waiver just to come to the
concert [ __ ] if you're if you're injured
in a moshing accident blah blah blah
like it's on you
and for pr wise that's crazy that's like
i forgot what scary movie did that but
they were like you got a sign you have
to consent to how scary it is people are
dying in the theater
from fear like amazing morgan yeah what
the [ __ ] movie was that the um
the something project where the light
was forest blair witch blair witch oh
maybe yeah blair which i think we all
thought might be real that was there's
like there's medical staff for the
theater because people are passing out
like that kind of thing they're having
seizures yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah like that kind of morgan was like
yo you wanna go to travis scott concert
you gotta sign away
and say yeah some [ __ ] happens like it's
on you haunted houses do that sometimes
like some haunted houses do that oh yeah
yeah they do i gotta go to that [ __ ]
haunted house just killing people yeah
yeah travis scott sales might skyrocket
to be honest with you
yeah i'm curious if it affects like
sneakers and [ __ ] like that
because he's also like beat this before
if we're talking about like case
precedence like he pled guilty to
disorderly conduct and like 2015
inciting a riot yeah you got discharged
from that like but this time eight
people died and it's a national fiasco
like we're all talking about yeah yeah
and even indifferent in his documentary
the one on netflix look magika fly he
has the same thing happen where like it
shows him encouraging the mob and like
he runs off stage and he's like whoa
that was crazy like they
banned him from like that venue or
something like that and it was used in
the promotion it's like all part of that
i do think it's all romantic until
people die yeah up until the point
people die that [ __ ] is lit as [ __ ] and
it might still be lit because more
people died and it might be that much
bigger but i think it gets a lot more
real when you're like oh eight people
died at this concert yeah but you're
also dealing with a fan base of 15 to 18
year olds yeah they're like i won't die
not gonna be me i'm bill different
that's so true they think they're
immortal but wow i didn't realize that
like this could actually help him yeah
good the concert is so lit he is so lit
that people are willing to die to get
close he's the greatest live artist ever
there's not even a debate anymore
right there there's inherently
son these concerts are killing people
how much more lit can you get i mean
people died the who people died
literally the who
you talking about 50 years ago
50 years ago that country concert in
vegas
yeah but that wasn't because of the
artist you say well that wasn't good
there's no motive stuff there's no
emotion it's trample in his dick you
still don't know what happened with that
right that's a little james paddock bro
right that investigation that just never
just went away like
yeah that's weird huh
yeah this is interesting man like people
are that uh
it's [ __ ] up to admit but i'm like i
gotta see travis scott concert that's
what i'm saying and now that all like
the aren't you glad i left my [ __ ] early
i might not be here tonight
i didn't feel
like i needed to see a travis scott
concert no you know until this and now
i'm like what is going on here stay back
there don't get close
satanic panic marketing always helps the
artist specifically what's that mean
like
saying oh they're demonic they're satan
it's a ritual which is like the big like
prevailing conspiracy on like facebook
and [ __ ] what's that and that kind of
thing always helps because like it's
offensive to like i think christian
puritanism but isn't so egregious that
like his audience will really care yeah
so it's like kind of just a perfect
device so all these people calling him
satan i think it actually helps because
it makes it so absorber they're like all
right it's not literally satan
and so it kind of creates like the it
makes a distance in a buffer between
like where he's actually culpable
because you make him so much worse than
what he actually did
you know what i mean
so if i'm his pr i'm like yo push the
satan [ __ ]
because then it's like he might have
incited of riot but he's not satan and
so now you're not saying look how bad
he's like well he's not that you're like
you're pulling back from how you switch
the combo yeah exactly yeah so now we're
not talking about dead people we're
talking about whether or not he's saying
push the same thing push the needle
thing push everything except he inside
of the ride yeah how upset you think
kris kardashian is why that she canceled
that [ __ ] show this year
there's no season imagine how lit that
season would be
the aftermath of killing eight people
they got all those episodes out of kim
getting a fake robbery these are the
real deaths kim and connie divorce
pete oh there's so much dude
the one year she stopped making up [ __ ]
to happen real things happen
it's crazy she's the real victim when
you think about it
you